all right they don't know exactly
where this errant rocket will land they
just know that it will happen this
weekend and
chances are with the earth 70 water most
statisticians say that means it would
land
somewhere on water and you don't have to
worry about it on land but here's the
problem with that theory
it's so big all bets are off and its
trajectory coming
into the atmosphere could be so wild at
guessing where it ends up well is
anyone's guess but to show you how big a
deal this
is uh this is roughly a hundred feet
long that this rocket is a hundred
feet long typical 18-wheeler about 70 to
feet long and it's a lot heavier than
that than
that i mean maybe up to 10 times heavier
than that and it's coming into the earth
here now
this is going to happen this weekend
we're told that it could happen anytime
between 10 a.m and 12 p.m
tomorrow night they're not saying that
but that's just when my saturday show
was on so i thought i'd
scare you into watching which is very
tacky and i apologize for that
but i do want to bring up michio kaku in
here the theoretical
uh physics professor author of the god
equation
and i think mitch i agree that maybe
only god knows exactly where this thing
will land
are you worried it's going to land on a
populated area
well you know this is the second the
second rocket
launched by the chinese that is wildly
swinging
uncontrollably last year it landed in
the atlantic ocean and parts of
africa so who knows where it's going to
land but just
remember that it's traveling at 18 000
miles per hour
that's 25 times the speed of sound and
it can whip around the earth
within just 90 minutes so we in new york
city
are actually in the crosshairs of this
satellite anywhere from as far north as
new york city
as far south as new zealand these cities
are in the crosshairs of this
device which is tumbling out of control
you know what i didn't understand the
chinese reaction has been
what we don't see any problem here no
apologies for it or concerns about it
uh and furthermore they have two more
planned launches
using this same technology where where
this could happen
again and again i'm wondering what are
they doing to help the world
figure this out or do they care you know
for the past
30 years the united states and russia
have deliberately planned deorbiting
their booster rockets
so that they don't land on someone's
backyard now the chinese are different
they're trying to play catch-up they
know that they're decades behind the
united states and russia
and so they're cutting corners they're
getting careless they want to launch as
many things as outer space as they can
and where they land well that's a
secondary priority for them i think
and so that's the fundamental problem
and realize that 30 years ago
the united states and russia used to do
this remember skylab
skylab was a 76-ton device that fell
in 1979 in australia that's where it
landed
and i still remember that bookies in las
vegas were taking bets
they were taking bets as to where skylab
would crash
and so remember this was something that
the great powers did 30 years ago
but not since this is the largest such
crap to come down in
30 years it is scary but
i know the odds are going over land and
furthermore of our land in the case of
skylab
uh it was apparently no one was affected
or hurt in that one
but the sheer size of this it makes me
think about the media or that hit russia
would it be akin to something like that
or is that a night and day comparison
well you know the chinese are trying to
downplay this by saying that it's going
to disintegrate in the atmosphere
but that's not the experience the actual
experience is that
between 20 to 40 of the object
will survive we'll survive reentry and
make
landfall somewhere on the planet earth
and because most of the earth's surface
is water
chances are it'll land in water and so
forth no one has ever died from a direct
impact from celestial debris from outer
space
but it can't be ruled out and remember
new york city
we are in the crosshairs of this
gigantic
monstrous rocket that is tumbling out of
control
incredible um you know the dinosaurs
might beg to differ with you admit you
know about
don't make a big deal or something
that's coming your way um
in fact i've booked one tomorrow to talk
to the no i haven't
but we'll see what happens on on all of
that so it's
sometime sometime this weekend that's
all we know mitchell always good seeing
you my friend
we'll keep an eye on this thing and get
the latest as you heard from the defense
secretary
no plans to try to shoot this thing down
but you must be thinking behind the
scenes
they're thinking of the unthinkable just
in case they have to start thinking
of that hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else